creative destruction risky business
going to the grind the reasonable man
adapts himself to the world unreasonable
one persists in trying to adapt the
world to himself I think I've been a lot
of people I was just telling all I said
as soon as this again we're gonna get
philosophical and we really can't it's
like just a matter to read just a matter
of time just a matter of time
Nipsey Hussle the rapper he's so
thoughtful about the way he produces his
songs and he paints such a clear picture
of his truth
[Music]
fifteen so you have it in memory I'll
tell you that nipsey is more of a
psychologist and kind of a you know a
thinker that way what's happening is
that there's a technological evolution
that's ahead of the compassionate
evolution to the the spiritual evolution
which is in the way movies catch up to
the technology as we got nuclear bombs
and everybody's harmed and we can come
in planetary suicide so what has to
balance that is the culture and that's
why Drake is the biggest hug I think in
the love is the movie no I pay attention
I'm a student of success in just like
boss moves
I'll pay attention to something you
don't gotta tell me directly the whole
concept of mob brand is the marathon so
I'm not a pageant card in that time and
I got my stores called in there you know
I love that yeah my man what every
[ __ ] word out of my mouth is marathon
over sprint everybody's running sprints
I've seen you a Gary Vee yeah a crazy
you know me it's hard tough now since he
walk in the room you feel it right now
but you know I got a lot of respect for
Gary Vee I called him a writer car call
myself a radical tool so I think we
relate when I love
thank you thank you um we had a good
talk early in the process right thank
you
yeah actually I'm gonna flip it up what
about some Nipsey Hussle snip see and
Ikey asked to get there yep like that so
the [ __ ] you think it's exciting right
now you know that's why I'm kind of
going slow as much as people like trying
to rush me I'm going slow cos I think
that way there's no need to rush I think
all the opportunities are unfocused if
you've got it like that gotta go you
gotta go
creative destruction a risky business is
going to grant the reasonable man adapts
himself to the world unreasonable one
persists in trying to adapt the world to
himself therefore all progress depends
on how reasonable man this radicals
nothing
you
[Music]